Hello and welcome to Introduction to Blueprints for Unreal Engine 5.6.
In this course, we're looking to achieve a number of different things,
but mainly we want you to come accustomed to and have a good foundation
in using our visual scripting language that's called Blueprints and is built into the engine.
So what we'd like to achieve is we'd like to go over some of the basics of object-orientated programming,
just some nuts so that you understand what's going on.
Then we'd like you to gain an understanding of how Blueprints touch the engine
and where this would work.
Next, we're going to spend a lot of time doing an exercise within the engine
so that you can actively go in and create your own Blueprints
using just simple node-based graphical system.
Finally, we'd like to do a little bit of work getting you to get actors to communicate with each other.
It doesn't make much sense yet, but it is a very useful skill
if you want to integrate some functionality into the engine.
In this video, we're going to go over just a couple of basic concepts,
so we're all starting with a similar foundation of knowledge.
First up, let's talk about what are Blueprints.
Now, I think the easiest way to understand this is to go back to the roots of Unreal.
Unreal is a game engine at heart.
It now works across many different industries, but it started out as a game engine.
What's interesting about gaming, much like other industries,
is you tend to have a mix of people of different specialties.
Now, Unreal is written in the programming language C++.
The thing about C++ is it's quite a complicated programming language,
and it's a relatively big ask for everybody who works within the engine
to have to go away and learn to code C++.
So what we did here quite early on
was we decided to expose some of the functionality of C++ into the editor.
And for this, we created a visual scripting language,
and that's called Blueprints.
Now, over the years, this scripting language has grown to be very powerful.
And at this point, there are quite a few games that are developed or released
which are either entirely written with Blueprints
or at least majoritatively written with Blueprints
with just little bits of functionality got away and written in C++.
Now, Blueprints are not necessarily as fast as C++,
but in most cases, they're almost comparative.
And because the code at compilation is converted to C++,
it's still very fast.
And in most cases, the code wouldn't be the bottleneck for your optimization.
So Blueprints really are a very plausible option when developing something.
Next up, we're going to have to talk a little bit about object-orientated programming language.
C++ is an object-orientated programming language.
But the main thing about object-orientated
is the code creates specific objects.
And these objects are born of classes, which are templates for code.
But you can have one class which can have numerous objects,
and each of these objects can have different settings and stats.
Now, this is very useful in a computer game
where you have lots of characters and elements to be part of a game.
All of them can share the same underlying code functionality,
but they'll all be contained within their own objects.
This should hopefully make more sense as we jump into the engine.
Next up, something that we're going to talk about a lot
is the concept of classes and instances.
So when you're in the engine, you'll see that we have a content browser,
which is effectively Unreal's file system,
where we can only see files which are of classes which Unreal understands.
And these classes are templates for what ultimately would be instances.
In this case here, we have the third person character,
which is what you control as a pawn if you're using the third person template.
But I've dragged three versions of it into the level, as you can see.
So these are all three unique instances of the same class.
And all of these would have their own settings and variables.
For example, if they were enemies, they might all have their own health,
which would be tracked independently on each instance.
Now, because it's an object-orientated programming language,
Unreal uses inheritance.
And this is where every class that you create within Unreal
will have a parent class associated with it
and can have one or multiple child classes associated with it.
Now, a child class will share the functionality and data
of each of its parent classes.
And therefore, this allows us to make code very modular,
meaning that we can program a whole lot of code into one class
and then just create child classes to it.
Which would share that functionality.
Now, this is an example of how inheritance might work.
At the top here in pink, we have object class.
And within C++, this would be UObject.
But this is the highest class which we will be working with in Unreal.
And this has a lot of very low level functionality attached to it.
The functionality that I've highlighted here is garbage collection.
Now, encoding what garbage collection is,
is when you have a class or an object or an instance
or something in memory, and you've decided you no longer need it,
so you mark it to be destroyed, it isn't automatically destroyed.
So there will be some memory which would be earmarked
for the use of that object.
Now, it isn't automatically got rid of within C++.
However, within Unreal, everything which inherits from the object class
will be part of Unreal's garbage collection system.
And that means that Unreal will go away
and it will clean up unused instances in memory
so that you can keep the game running smoothly.
So it's just a whole load of functionality
that we don't need to worry about creating ourselves
because it's already there.
A child class of the object, amongst many others,
is the actor class.
Now, the actor class is very prominent in games
because an actor class will have a transform.
And a transform is details of an actor's location, rotation, and scale.
These are what's required in order to create it
within a 3D space and simulation.
Now, the actor has that functionality in it
and nothing else in the class itself,
but it will be the parent class to anything
which needs to exist within your level
and not just in memory.
The next child class of actor we have is Plaw.
And this has the extra functionality
of being able to be possessed and receive input
from a controller.
What a controller would do is then it could possibly
listen for keyboard, mouse, or controller inputs,
or it could be a controller in memory,
a stuff like an A.I. controller for the enemies, for example.
But either way, the Plaw has the functionality
of being possessed and receiving input.
Now, this makes the Plaw the perfect parent class
for the character.
Now, what a character class does
is it adds a couple of different components
which are used for different functionality
as well as some other functionality.
But the character class would have a skeletal mesh, for example.
And that's what would represent usually our character
where we would see animated within a scene.
It also has something called the movement component.
And this adds functionality and logic
for doing stuff like running and jumping.
So our character class is inheriting functionality
from the Plaw to be able to be possessed,
from the Actor to be able to exist in the world,
and from the Object class to do a lot of low-level functionality
like garbage collection.
Classes don't need to have just one child.
The class can have multiple children,
and they can do multiple different functionality.
For example, the Object doesn't have just the Actor class.
It would also have the Actor component
as one of its children class.
It has the ability to be attached to an Actor.
And there would also be a lot of data-only classes.
So a lot of classes which are loaded into memory,
but not necessarily have any visual component
or exist within the world.
That brings us to the end of our introduction and concepts.
We will go over a number of these concepts again
whilst we are in the engine and in a project.
But that should hopefully give us a good foundation to start from.
Thanks for listening.